and luke weaver will take them out this
afternoon against the seattle mariners
as you said bb chance to win a series
that's a kind of a new twist here lately
step in the right direction you're gonna
have to do more than win series if they
want to get where they want to go so
marmo two for four three rbis
siegert first they'll be running two
outs three and two yeah he's hit that on
the button down into the corner stays
fair seeger's gonna score easily as it
rattles around in the corner
and marmaleo's continues to hammer
pitching getting it done his five-game
hitting streak he picks up an rbi at
17th and americans have a one-nothing
lead
winging a miss on the fastball two
strikeouts for luke seattle strikes
first diamondbacks coming up and justin
dunn the 24 year old right-hander making
his a start on the year three-in-one
record era just over four and 33 innings
he has 25 strikeouts 20 walks on the
aerial one and wants to stay away from
the walks
over three with a walk-in and start at
second base in last night's game
that's this one deep to center field
dylan moore is out there froze at first
still backing up but it's off the wall
and here we go rojas is on the run
here he comes here's the relay hits
offline
and he's in there we are tied the rbi
double for josh van meter high off the
wall in center
donovan a chance to pick up a run or two
or three
look at the out at first the score run
down he won't picks up the run mariners
get the lead back at two to one
[Applause]
jumps on a breaking ball that's gonna
work base hit
third hit since joining the mariners
down and got it blistered it right past
the diving band meter
odom
will hold at third
absolute bullet by ty france
here comes donovan walton with two outs
and two on 2-1 mariners
swinging walton shoots this deep out to
center field jay racing back out of the
warning track it bangs off the wall
marmaleo sprinting around third he
scores standing d coming home excuse me
irvin coming home and he scores
donovan walton stands up at second base
his first career
big league extra base hit it drives in
two and makes it now 4-1 mariners lead
ahmed trying to bun his way on
savage pounces on it but no play nick's
aboard
why not you need base runners you trail
by three runs in the ball game even if
nick hits a solo homer you're still down
good
these all seegers drop way back at third
base
first pitch swing and they worked him
away again marmalajos in left field
and we've played six settings at chase
field d-backs trailer 4-1
even smith sends one out to right field
and he's got a second big league hit a
lead off single in the seventh that's a
start
[Applause]
and nader knocks it into right field
they're gonna stop haven smith at third
and with nobody out in the seventh
inning the diamondbacks have the bases
full
and the batter is christian walker
bouncer to first evan white has got it
they get a one
they cannot turn two as smith makes it
4-2
center field dylan moore coming in rojas
is at third here he comes
rbi for calhoun it's a one-run ball game
kevin white phillip irvin here in the
eighth
past the diving second baseman rojas
base head
that's a good start to the eighth inning
there you go that's hitting a fastball
96 miles an hour he committed to it
it's hard that's what you want to see
right there good swing first two men
have reached big spot for phillip
bourbon mariners by run one
two men aboard here in the eighth
well he jumps on this down the line
fairball fair ball
lewis will score
and white makes it to third phillip
bourbon with an rbi and americans get a
little breathing room five to three in
the eighth inning
the look in by guerra two on two out to
run in and the 1-1 pitch way up high and
off the glove of the catcher varshall
all the way to the backstop and here
comes evan white on to score on a wild
pitch by garen the mariners now lead the
diamondbacks six to three here in the
top half of the eighth inning
up the middle base head that extends his
hitting straight to four ball games
kyle hits this one hard center field
line drive right at jay
dylan moore
he's going to score the mariners have a
7-3 lead good job kyle lewis
3-2 pitch
[Applause]
hit well irvin
got it nice play
fella bourbon's been busy
in every game in this series in arizona
he makes the catch two down in the ninth
right about the first couple of games
he's been fairly quiet but they decided
to test him
on his way out the door i wasn't sure
he's going to get there to cover some
ground
a snow cone and a diving catch
one and two
to walker
got it
tag applied game over mariners win 7-3
take the series two games to one they're
now 21 and 25 on the season